c'est comme si quelqu'un prenait de
marteau pays frappé les deux oreilles en
même temps un bruit issu d'un très fort
il y a deux ans en quelques secondes
seulement un choc acoustique ébranle
craig pollock
j'ai subi une commotion cérébrale
j'avais tous les symptômes la nausée le
mal de tête instantanée depuis j'ai des
acouphènes contente et pigiste pour le
fédéral mais aussi dans le secteur privé
en tout il a eu trois accidents de
travail dans le privé mais les risques
sont partout selon lui
je pense que les deux acteurs sont à
saussines l'heure selon les données du
bureau de la traduction du gouvernement
fédéral
le quart des interprètes ont souffert
d'acouphènes ou des chocs acoustiques
dans les trois dernières années
nausées vomissements évanouissement père
d'équidés des orientations accompagnée
d'une perte d'audition soit temporaire
ou permanente
le développement des communications à
distance à augmenter le risque de chocs
acoustiques chez les interprètes venus
de plus en plus de conférences à
distance les personnes au téléphone ont
l'équipement dont la qualité peut varier
énormément
aucun des appareils utilisés au
parlement et au fédéral ne respecte les
nouvelles normes internationales
d'interprétation faut se rattraper puis
rattrapé la technologie le bureau de la
traduction fait appel au secteur privé
pour trouver une solution
le but protéger les interprètes en
contrôlant mieux le son des solutions
existent déjà croise est
audioprothésiste tout seul ça peut se
faire à l'intérieur d'une prothèse
auditive
donc je vois pourquoi ça pourrait pas se
faire dans le cadre d un interprète
parce que c'est vraiment le même presse
en attendant le gouvernement à
distribuer aux interprètes un dispositif
permettant de limiter le volume du son
dans leurs écouteurs et ont au moins un
outil qui vont les protéger pendant que
tous ces changements leur arrive pendant
qu'on s'assure que l'équipement et de
est de la plus haute qualité
les employés vont être satisfaits
lorsque le risque est réduit à zéro
les interprètes du bureau de la
traduction devront s'armer de patience
le gouvernement se donne deux ans pour
choisir la prochaine technologie ici et
c'est le côté sroka radio canada ottawa